thank you and hello everyone this is
joint work with ghosts of the sky like
signal and Diggle bomb i will talk to
you today about the framework to compute
optimal actions ok let's start with a
standard setting where we have one
sailor and he has one or many items he
said and he's interested in maximizing
his revenue and the main question is
which oxygen sudhir on to maximize his
revenue and throughout the whole talk
will be focusing on the case of a single
buyer who is additive ok so in a single
item case the standard-setting says that
there is a distribution we're like the
cellular doesn't know the value of the
buyer exactly but knows somehow a
distribution about his value and in this
case the optimum thing to do is to give
him a price some price P star that
maximizes the expected Vicki's expected
revenue so the meyerson 81 proved that
this mechanism is a optimal for single
item setting and if you look at the
buyer the buyer who can plot his utility
he receives under this mechanism which
is a if he doesn't if his value is less
than P star he doesn't get anything and
gets utility 0 y lift his value is
larger dubster his utility increases
linearly as his values gets larger ok so
but in the multi-item case the cell
there's a joint distribution that gives
the buyers value for the items again but
now it's much less clear what the
optimal mechanism is and there has this
is a very important problem
economics and there has been a lot of
work trying to understand what the
seller should do in these settings but I
had the progress has been slow and and
the K this problem is very difficult
even with just two items I will now give
you some examples to illustrate why this
problem is so complicated so in the
first example consider two items stable
mr. and consider a buyer whose values
are independent for the items and are
uniformly distributed between one dollar
into dollars okay so since he's a his
vows are independent and he's a
completely additive about the items the
obvious think the obvious mechanism to
run would be to run the milestone
separately for each item and sell each
item separately this would result in
pricing each item at one dollar and
achieving a expects driving for the
seller of two dollars however although
this seems intuitively this should be
intuitively true because the items are
uncorrelated and we can get much better
revenue by grouping the items together
and selling the band lot three dollars
in this case the by the buyer will buy
the bundle of both items seventy-five
percent of the time and she will pay
three dollars so the expected revel in
this case it will be two dollars and
twenty-five cents which is larger than
what we would get by pricing separately
so the key message from this slide is
that it's not we don't want to always
sell items separately but we might want
to bundle items to increase revenue as a
second example consider what happens
when the high value for the chair
increases from two dollars to three
dollars
okay so here the optimal mechanism isn't
that simple it's a bit more complicated
gives the two options to the buyer if
either tells him by both items for four
dollars or you can pay two dollars and
fifty cents and get the table
probability one well the chair with
probability half if you do the math
fifty percent of the time he buys the
first option and a quarter of the time
he buys the second option and the
revenue is two point six to five dollars
well any deterministic mechanism for
this setting can give at most two point
five dollars okay so the key methods is
that optimal mechanisms may not just
bundle items but they might also use
randomness to increase the sellers
driving okay as the third example to
show you the things can get much more
complicated considered to continue
distributions like bet parametrized by
one and two and here the optimal
mechanism is not doesn't have a simple
description it actually offers many
different bundles I with different
probabilities for each for each item and
in fact it's not just inflate laments
uncountably infinite so as you can see
the optimal meccans can be very
complicated so to summarize even the
even in such a simple setting where
we'll have one buyer with who is
additive and his values are independent
for the items the optimal mechanism it
can be complicated might band light them
together it might require randomization
and it might offer uncountably many
choices
okay so given all these complications
one natural question arises which is how
do we find this optimal action how do we
know what the optimal action is and even
a more simpler question even if we're
given a mechanism and you were told this
is a good mechanism run this for your
company or something is it possible to
certify that this mechanism is optimal
and there won't be somebody else that
gets creates a new mechanism gets more
revving so how do we there are two
generic approaches for certifying
optimality of solutions in optimization
so one one approach would be to
formulate the whole problem as a concave
optimization problem and in that
situation we just need to check whether
our solution satisfies the first-order
conditions okay if we take that the
first article satisfied we know since
the problem is concave that the solution
is optimal and such an approach is taken
for by marcin for the single item case
but as far as we know it's really hard
to extend this approach to more items
okay so instead when this approach fails
a standard alternative is to use duality
and complementary slackness which is
what we do in this work so now I will
briefly go through our our main results
that I'm will present them later so our
main theorem is that the optimal the
optimal oxygen design problem find
computing the optimal location for this
case for over the case of one buyer has
a dual problem that it takes the form of
an optimal transportation and this in
fact we can show that this duel is tight
and what is the point of this by getting
a tight duel to the problem it means
that every optimal auction because the
for any auction that exists is
certificate to prove its optimality and
that certificate takes the form of a
transportation flow so and the way to
check whether the oxygen is truthful is
through complementary slackness we could
just take the oxygen that we have and
the solution for the transportation
fluid coat check if complementary
slackness satisfied and as a corollary
of this of our main theorem we can
obtain a complete characterization of
optimal move the item auctions and as an
example we can so for example that grand
band link which is grouping all items
together and selling them for a single
price is optimal if and only if some to
stochastic dominus conditions are
satisfied between some measures that you
derive from the distribution F and I
will explain how you get those measures
now ok but before we get before we get
there yes the valuation of the buyers
are GPS not assuming anything on the
distributions are so they don't have to
be regular they don't have to be it can
be arbitrary correlate do it I'm
accusation even when the distributions
are regular oh yes so by the
distributions are regular and even if
they are randomization even if they you
have independent distributions you get
all this but the framework applies in
for correlated distributions the only
assumption we make is that they are
differentiable and continues okay so
how would we approach this problem what
is a good way to optimize over actions
so that one approach would be to
enumerate all possible options to give
to the buyer optimize over what options
the buyer should get yeah but then this
is very problematic as we've seen
because these options might be
infinitely many okay and Tiffany's and
Alou if we had all these options it
would be hard to understand with the
option the buyer would prefer given this
whole menu of choices so how do this
seems like really hard to work in this
space so more standard approach is to
search instead of our allocation and
pricing functions what does means is
that we can have the function that given
the evaluation of for the items for the
buyer it gives us directly what what
items should get with what probabilities
and what price he should pay so a
problem with this approach is that we
need to somehow keep too many values for
for every type we need to keep all the
probabilities for all the items and the
price and another problem is a that we
must make sure that what we're actually
giving to the buyer is what you would
choose given all that all the
alternatives that we want to make sure
that the mechanism is truthful okay so
what we do instead is optimized over
utility functions
what that means is that any if you think
of any possible mechanism if you
consider the type z which is the type
corresponds to the chromatic values all
the items he enjoys some utility give Z
other any possible mechanism okay in the
characterization by rasa the jedis
characterization that tells us that some
function U is induced by a mechanism if
I not leave this conditions are
satisfied it is one lipsett convex non
decreasing and non- this means that if
any mechanism gives such a utility
function and if you have a such a
utility function there exists a
mechanism that I has this that has this
you think that gives utility to the
buyers okay and what's even more nice
about the characterization is that if
you look at the gradient of the utility
function you get directly the allocation
probabilities for the items okay so you
get exactly who what fraction or what
with what probability you should give
its item to the buyer okay and since you
know that you can compute the price at
the buyer pays to the mechanism by
computing the expected value if he gets
for the items- utility so given this
characterization we can simply express
the expected revenue for the seller in
this closed form okay so this is a nice
closed form but it's a would be even
nicer if you didn't have these gradients
at least derivatives so we can simplify
it even further by applying the
divergence theorem which gets rid of the
gradients from the utility and
assist them to the distribute to the
distribution F so by applying the
divergence theorem we can rewrite the
problem purely in terms of you and not
of any derivatives of you wear and
define this measure knew that
corresponds to this function of the
distribution with this is assigned
measure meal and it gives you the
expected revenue okay so to summarize
optimizing over over all auctions it's
as simple as solving this optimization
problem you have a linear functional of
your utility and you have you want to
pick a faction you that these convex
continues and it's one lip seeds and to
satisfy that if you value item 0 you get
you till 20 and you want to maximize
your revenue and to give you some more
intuition about what you're trying to do
if you decompose new into its positive
part at the negative part what you want
to do is you want to make the utility
function large where mu is positive and
the utility small worm is negative okay
so this is the problem and now we'll
explain how
and I will explain how the duels for
this problem looks like okay so think of
this partition of the space into this
positive region of this negative region
okay I think of new place and new minus
has grains of sand okay what is the the
dual problem asks us to do is to move
eastham is to transform the pile of sand
new plus into new- by moving these
grains of sand as long as little as
possible ok so if so what it tells us
that if there is a cost for moving one
unit of mass from one point to the other
what is the minimum cost way to
transform new plus into new- so this is
a dual for this problem and it has been
exploding prior work by us and there's
also by an accomplice in coaches who
have work worked on the similar duel and
but it turns out that all these
approaches crucially rely on the fact
that you that the convex the constraint
is removed from your primal ok so this
isn't the exact do love the problem that
I described but it is the dual of the
problem after you remove the convexity
constraint and tifa and you have a more
computer science background this might
remind you of the min-cost massing
duality in the Maine coast matching
problem you usually have there is this
bipartite graph what you want too much
nodes from one side to the other and you
want to find the minimum cost matting
and this is usually the primal and the
dual corresponds to this potential
function these potentials that we'd
usually
fine so my point here is that this is
somehow a dual to this problem but it's
not the correct dwell it's only a week
duel with suffice sometimes to prove
optimality of some auctions but doesn't
always work so what I want to do now is
to bring back the convexity constraint
and try to look how the correct duel for
this problem looks like and it turns out
that is very similar to before but I
only have one extra operation you can
take any any point mass and split it
into many points as long as the mean is
preserved as long as the center of mass
of the points you have created his
remains the same and this you can do all
these thing all these moves for free ok
so and the way we prove this result is a
we threw some measures theoretic lemmas
and the proof is really similar to the
Monte Carlo Rob's to aldi where we go
through the steps and try to account for
the convexity constraint ok so this is
we have identified a duel which is tied
for this problem but what what does
what's the point of that what does tight
mean the point is that every optimal
action now not it doesn't only work
sometimes it works always and it means
that every optimal location has a
certificate that can prove its up demand
ok so in particular if you're given a
candid mechanism you can always find you
can always find
dual solution in terms of this
transportation problem and use the
slackness condition to certify its
optimality and moreover that even if you
didn't have a solution even if they have
a candidate mechanism what you can do is
reverse engineer the slackness condition
to identify what the optimal mechanism
should be it gives you it proves down a
lot on the search space for your
mechanisms so in the paper in this work
we give examples of both of these cases
and more importantly using this theorem
and working with these complementary
slackness conditions behind the scenes
we can obtain a complete
characterization of optimal mechanisms
that doesn't have to do anything with
duality and uses this duality theorem
only as a proof technique and we discuss
next how what the this characterization
isn't how optimal actions look like okay
so let's consider the case as a warm-up
the case where we have two items and we
want to check whether selling the grand
bundle is optimal these partitions the
type space in the two sets according to
this this line this 45 degree line and
in one set here the buyer receives no
good and in the other side he gets both
items and he pays beasts are so the
utility is linear in the top part and 0
in the bottom okay and what the
complimentary slackness condition tells
us is that after you perform all these
mass spreads or after you do all these
free moves where you got allowed to
split
to split the mass as long as you
preserve the scent the center of mass
you should be able too much if this
mechanism is optimal you should always
be able to match nu plus 2 nu minus x
only moving mass southwest leg or down
and to the left ok and turns out that
hey make it more explicit some water
than you know to distribution that you
need to move from one to another so it's
a you have computed this measure this
new how does this you can then relate to
the original big f so there is a form
like some take some gradients of the big
f you and try to get a sense of how
explicit this is so it oh there's a
closed-form description of New given
this can go quick you back so so this is
new this area this is the density mu
so you have you get this new all the way
it was uniform can you tell me what you
is simply already going to be a uniform
it's a constant it's a minus 3
everywhere inside then they'd say one on
the boundaries so given any distribution
you can compute exactly what what this
measure is the original f was uniform
that here you get something on the
boundary and yet something on the inside
negative inside posted on the corner yes
and they and the idea is that if this
would be optimal you should be able to
match all the mass all the positive mass
within this region but just by going
down and left okay and but it turns out
that after applying stress and theorem
this property of moving mass down on the
left is this exactly the same as the
condition that new plus first order
dominates new mines in that in the
region tip and notice that this
statement is aftermath spreads and if we
account for mass spreads all together
this condition becomes exactly the
second order condition dominance
condition of new plus the new- in this
region T and the characterization says
that the mechanism the grandest bundling
mechanism is optimal if I not leave this
condition and the similar condition for
the region Z holds that if the if both
of these conditions hold yes okay so
optimality boils down just taking this
to measure thoroughly conditions and we
can extend this even further so even for
many items and arbitrary mechanisms what
you can do is you can partition the
whole space into regions based on the
the choice that the buyer would buy from
the menu and you derive one stochastic
dominance condition / region and the
mechanism will be optimal if and only if
all these Dominus conditions are true
okay so to give you a more concrete
example how how we can use this
characterization let's consider the
following the following case we have one
buyer and his values for the items are
uniform CC plus one okay and and the
question is when when is banking if
bundling would be optimal so we can so
that for every end for every number no
matter what n is there exists a large
enough c0 a large enough threshold that
if c is greater than this threshold
there's a selling all items together in
a bundle is optimal ok so this yes so we
can solve this by proving that the
existed price says that both of these
dominance conditions are satisfied in
the region where she gets the item of
the region which doesn't and this is
intuitively true because the more the
larger sees the more concentrated his
value for the items seized so the just
grouping all the atoms together and
selling them as one is very close to his
expected value so it you get almost it
with a trivial argument you can so that
is really close to optimal and it's in
fact optimal but what's not that
intuitive you can so the OS an opposite
statement let's say that for all see
there exists a large enough threshold n0
so that if the ID number of items is
greater than the threshold then
this grant bagley mechanism is not
optimal and this is counterintuitive
because the same argument could be used
in this case because as you increase the
number of items again the valley
concentrates and there and selling all
the islands together becomes
increasingly better and better but even
if it started for being optimal for some
men as you increase the number of items
it stops being optimal after that after
point but do you know what is
asymptotically of SM it becomes large is
probably as metronic the optimum it's
really close it's approximately optimal
but there is always some small gap where
you can do something else never becomes
up tomorrow yeah so let me summarize and
yeah so basically we saw this by proving
that there exists no such price where
the Dominus conditions are true and
because a characterization condition is
a FN on leaf statement this mechanism
can't be optimal so in conclusion we pin
down the correct duel for the problem of
designing craving optimal actions and by
achieving this strong duality this
getting the tight duel when going
through the complementary slackness
conditions we can obtain a complete
characterization of optimal oxygens and
there there are many open problems for
after this work then one major question
is to generalize it to more bidders and
understand understand what we have the
optimal actions look like in those
settings and or general consider more
objectives and other allocation
constraints I think Costas will be
talking later in the discussion about
different problems in this in the
multi-dimensional mechanics design
literature
thank you questions next video screen
what's the most l the structure you have
to consider what the statute of the
problem becomes much different because
the utility you don't have this nice
characterization with the utility I
think and maybe you can derive some kind
of flow but yet the conditions for the
utility function are not as simple as l1
being a one lip seeds it's a much more
complicated condition you need to yeah
either if you are looking for base
incentive compatible mechanisms you have
to incorporate border if you're looking
for dominant strategy said to go by the
mechanisms you have to explore the space
i guess it's hard to understand
okay let's thank you